it's amorosa versus president trump plus
the alt-right anniversary rally fizzles
and ends he flick continues to threaten
Public Safety Plus updates from the FBI
lots and lots of stuff going on I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
there's a really busy weekend filled
with joy and also weirdness people
sending me very odd messages about why
James Bond shouldn't be a black person
which is a very weird thing but we'll
get to all of those things first I want
to mention to you that inflation is a
real possibility what we actually have
seen is an increase in wages there's
been a minimum wage increase across the
country plus we're seeing rising prices
thanks to rising import prices and trade
wars raw materials prices are increasing
thanks to tariffs rising housing prices
while the government sometimes solves
inflation by printing more money and
that is why you should have at least
part of your portfolio in precious
metals my savings plan is diversified
and yours should be - the company that I
trust with precious metal purchases it's
Birch gold group and right now thanks to
a little-known IRS tax law you could
even move your IRA or eligible 401k into
an IRA backed by physical gold and
silver it's perfect for folks who want
to protect hard-earned retirement
savings from future geopolitical
uncertainty when you look back
historically what you see is that when
the bottom falls out of everything else
Gold tends to safeguard savings that's
why Birch gold group has thousands of
satisfied customers countless five-star
reviews an A+ rating with the Better
Business Bureau contact Birch gold group
right now to request a free information
kit on physical precious metals it's a
comprehensive 16-page kit that reveals
how gold and silver can protect your
savings how you can legally move that
IRA or 401k out of stocks and bonds if
you wish and into a precious metals IRA
to get that no-cost no-obligation kit go
to birchgold.com slash Ben that's
birchgold.com slash Ben the slash Ben
lets them know that we saying you all
right so the fresh controversy of the
weekend is Omarosa Omarosa Manigault the
villain from three seasons of Celebrity
Apprentice well she's back and better
than ever the president made the
brilliant move of hiring her to the
White House for no apparent reason and
then he fired her because it turns out
she's a crazy person and then it turns
out that she was taping people in like
the Situation Room which is not good
I've been to the White House you're not
supposed to tape in the Situation Room
in fact you're probably not supposed to
tape anywhere in the White House
however Omarosa was doing just that and
then she goes on national TV to
demonstrate how inside she was she's
very angry because apparently john kelly
then the chief of staff he said that he
was firing her and she got mad and then
she went and talked to Trump and then
Trump because he is always afraid of
actually firing people dirt a little
secret about Trump you hadn't liked
firing people he actually likes his
subordinates to fire people or he likes
for them to quit so she went to John
Kelly and John Kelly
you can leave and then she went to Trump
said Trump said I don't know anything
about this and she has both of them on
tape well she was on Meet the Press
over the weekend talking about how she
was taping inside the Situation Room
which is not great and here's what she
had to say they take me into the
Situation Room the doors are locked
they tell me I can't leave and they
start to threaten me put fear in me the
question is why not have the meeting in
the chief of staff's office why put me
in the Situation Room lock the door and
tell me over and over again as they'll
hear well you don't hear his part that I
couldn't leave that I couldn't consult
an attorney that I couldn't talk to my
husband who was sitting outside of the
door yes I was prepared ok so she says
how dare they bring you in there ok
wasn't false imprisonment they didn't
kidnap her they didn't keep her there
locked up she would have a lawsuit if
they had ok this is this is all a wildly
overblown then she says I don't
understand why they fired me and then
she plays tape of her secretly taping
the chief of staff I can't imagine why
they fired Omarosa I just can't imagine
this does raise some questions about the
White House's staffing choices like why
would they do this in the first place
I had heard repeatedly that the
president chooses only the best people
she was one of his first hires so not
quite the best people the White House
released a statement that CNN reported
on here with CNN reporting on the White
House response to amorosa we just got a
statement from Sarah Sanders the White
House press secretary and it reads the
very idea of staff member would sneak a
recording device into the White House
Situation Room shows a blatant disregard
for our national security and then to
brag about it on national television
further proves the lack of character and
integrity of this disgruntled former
White House employee okay so the White
House obviously smacking back hard at
Omarosa and then Rhonda McDaniel Romney
McDaniel she she came for she's the GOP
chairwoman and she tweeted out who in
their right mind thinks it's appropriate
to secretly record the White House chief
of staff in the Situation Room and the
answer is nobody which is why she
shouldn't been hired in the first place
this is who I'm Rosen Manigault is
anybody who doesn't know differently has
never had any experience that Moroso
Manigault there was a story out today
about how Omarosa actually tried when
she was getting married to invade the
White House with her photographer in her
wedding dress and go take wedding photos
in the Rose Garden at the White House
which is not what the White House is for
the President of the United States of
course
would not take this lying down at I mean
listen this is what this is what we
bargain for right I mean we're getting a
lot of the good policy it comes with the
downside of this reality TV show so the
president tweeted out three things this
morning about Omarosa Manigault and
basically it is the Godfather one two
and three of tweets it's pretty
spectacular so Godfather Part 1 he
tweets out whacky Omarosa who got fired
three times on the apprentice now got
fired for the last time she never made
it never will she begged me for a job
tears I said okay people in the White
House hated her she was vicious but not
smart I would rarely see her but heard
dot dot dot dot dot
okay so let's analyze Godfather Part 1
it's a great tweet it's a great tweet
for a variety of reasons first of all
wacky Omarosa
I do love that his first hires were
sloppy Steve Bennett and wacky amorosa
it's it's like the Muppets and he gives
them all nicknames Oscar the Grouch was
the Secretary of State got rid of him -
that was Rex Tillerson who apparently
was fired on the toilet I mean if you
didn't bargain for this reality TV show
then I'm not sure what you're about
getting for and then he says she was
fired three times on the apprentice and
now got fired for the last time he fired
her three times on the apprentice and
then rehired her three times so I mean
there's someone who's sort of missing
from this equation he says she never
made it and never will well she didn't
get a million-dollar advance apparently
for this book he says she begged me for
a job tears in her eyes whenever the
president says that sort of stuff
whenever he says they begged me they
came and they begged me on their knees
that just means that they asked for a
job and he said yes and he said okay and
these people in the White House hated
her my favorite line from this classic
Godfather tweet I mean this is Godfather
Part one it is a classic of the tweeting
genre he'd like this prices she was
vicious but not smart I like the but
they're right there that vicious is
actually a compliment right vicious is
is an accolade she was vicious which is
awesome but not very smart
so she's stupid but also vicious so that
was her recommending qualities that she
was vicious so Godfather Part one of
tweets excellent and then we get to the
even better one Godfather Part two of
tweets it turns out the sequel is even
stronger than the original he says I
heard really bad things
nasty to paper and would constantly miss
meetings and work when general Kelley
came
bird he told me she was a loser and
nothing but problems I told him to try
working it out if possible because she
only said great things about me until
she got fired ah ah the genius the
genius of constructing a godfather to
tweet like this so spectacular I love it
the entire tweet is what a terrible
person she was she was nasty to paper
she'd constantly miss meetings and work
she was the worst
but Trump wanted to keep her around why
why because she only said great things
about me that was legitimately his
hiring criteria she was making by the
way 180 thousand dollars in taxpayer
money at the White House for saying nice
things about him while he was saying to
choose the worst employee ever so
fantastic so and also a window into the
mind of the commander in chief and when
people say that Trump is nice to Putin
because he's in bed with Putin or he's
nice to Kim Jong hoon because in bed
with Kim Jong hoon no he's nice to them
because when they say nice things about
them he likes them this is not a
complicated man okay it's so funny when
you when you talk to women and men about
relationships women will always tell men
are so complex men are not complex men
are super super simple you feed them
ladies if you're married feed them have
sex with them be relatively nice to them
happy marriage we're done men are really
really simple
president Trump be nice to him feed him
depends on who you are with the sex but
in any case the president is a just like
any other man except more so so it's
really not hard to keep the plan the
president please like you say nice
things about him and he is very very
pleased with you so I love this he said
she was nasty to people missed meetings
missed work was terrible Kelly wanted to
fire her he's like right but she says
some stuff about me and it makes me feel
great about myself so I was Godfather
Part two of tweets very very strong
entry in the Canon and then we get to
the slightly disappointing Godfather
Part three of tweets it has its moments
its highs and it's lows but overall
doesn't really fit in the series he
tweets out well I know it's not
presidential to take on a low-life like
Omarosa and well I would rather not be
doing so this is a modern-day form of
communication and I know the fake news
media will be working overtime to make
even wacky Omarosa look legitimate as
possible sorry now
listen it's fine for what it is it's a
bit of a derivative storyline is the
truth this particular tweet link you
know it's just more of the same yeah
it's not presidential and I'm not
presidential but I'm communicating with
the people okay I get it fine but it's
not it's not his strongest war Godfather
if I had to rank these Suites Godfather
part to tweet Godfather Part one treat
and then Godfather Part three tweet okay
but very strong entries from the
president overall
on his Twitter account and come on if
we're not gonna get mused by this then
what can you be amused by the man hired
a doofus and then he's like I don't know
how she even got in here but I kept her
here cuz she said nice things but then
she got fired she won't get a job ever
again
unless she begs with tears in her eyes
this is what listen I know a lot of
people are gonna be frustrated because
they say well why can't you just focus
on the good stuff the president is doing
don't worry what gets some of the good
stuff the president is doing we do that
whenever possible but if the president
gets credit for all of his staffers
doing good stuff he also gets the blame
when his staffer ends up being amorosa a
person he never should have hired in the
first place he does get the blame when
he hires Steve Ben and a person who
never should have hired in the first
place he does get the blame when he
hires Rex Tillerson a person he never
should have hired in the first place
when you're the boss you get the blame
and the credit for what your employees
do and the president of the United
States hired Omarosa Manigault because
she was on a reality TV show with him
and because let's face it the President
of the United States wanted more black
faces around him because he wanted to be
able to say to the media he had a more
diverse administration and so he hired
Omarosa Manigault there is no chance
that if she were not black she would've
been inside the administration she
doesn't have the qualifications the
president hired her based on an
affirmative action calculation I know
that's politically incorrect to say but
that is why he hired her in the first
place that is what the president was
doing here okay so he gets the blame
when it turns out that she is exactly
the type of feces storm that everybody
knew that she was in the first place and
of course she brought a recording device
into the skiff of course she did of
course she brought into the Situation
Room which is a which is a confidential
place
did she violate the law by the way is
she gonna go to jail for this probably
not in order to violate the law you
actually have to show intent to
communicate all this stuff to outside
intelligence agencies or something like
that she's not gonna go to jail for any
of this but the President does have to
get better with his staff and thankfully
I think the president's staff has gotten
a lot better I know a lot of folks in
the administration they seem to be an
upgrade over the people who are
generally in the administration but come
on if we can't have a little bit of
light-hearted fun with the fact the
president hired Omarosa Manigault to be
part of the administration then tweeted
about how terrible she was except she
was nice to him
I don't know what we can't have fun with
these days okay in a minute I'm gonna
get to the actual alt-right rally that
happened over the weekend and Tifa the
media malfeasance we have we have a lot
to get to first I want to talk to you
about making your business better so
let's say you don't want to staff up
with a bunch of Omarosa Manigault so
let's say that you look around your
office and you're like wow that person
is gonna take me in the Situation Room
let's say you're president from and you
want to hire better
well maybe you oughta head over to zip
recruiter because zip recruiter is going
to do a lot better than your former
apprentice hires zip recruiter sends
your job so for 100 of the web's leading
job boards they don't stop there with
their powerful matching technologies zip
recruiter scans thousands of resumes to
find people with the right experience
and invite them to apply to your job as
applications come in zip recruiter
analyzes each one they spot like the top
candidates so you never miss a great
match zip recruiter is so effective that
80% of employers who post on zip
recruiter can a quality candidate
through the site within the first day we
use zip recruiter here at daily wire all
the time it is a fantastic service it's
no wonder the zip recruiter is the
highest rated hiring site in the United
States and right now my listeners can
try zip recruiter for free at this
exclusive web address zip recruiter comm
slash daily wire that zip recruiter comm
slash Dai ly WI re its zip recruiter
calm slash daily wire zip recruiter is
indeed the smartest way to hire go check
it out zip recruiter comm slash daily
wear okay so putting all the Omarosa
stuff aside it was a weekend of covering
stupidity so does Omarosa deserve all of
this media coverage no of course she
doesn't deserve all this media coverage
you know what else didn't deserve a lot
of media coverage over the weekend this
alt-right rally that started off in
Charlottesville Virginia near the
University of Virginia and then
transferred its way over to Washington
DC now the reason it got a lot of
coverage is because last year of course
that alt-right rally drew several
hundred people and it's evolved into
violence when auntie Faye showed up and
there are a bunch of pitched battles in
the streets between some antifoam
members and some members of the
alt-right
neo-nazi rally and then that bled over
into an alright piece of human debris
crashing his car into members of a of a
left-wing rally some of whom are antifa
many of whom are not in any case that
became national news not only
the killing but also because the
President of the United States then got
up there and said that there were good
people on both sides which I think was
eminently untrue in any case the media
was there in full force for this
anniversary all right rally the governor
of Virginia declared a state of
emergency over this alt-right rally hey
here's how many people showed up we have
video of the ralliers on the way to
Washington DC here is this is
legitimately all of them all of them
okay they could fit in half a car it was
20 people you can see this half of the
half of the car is members of the media
and the rest of it is is the actual
people that the car's half-empty it's
like 20 people the last time this few
losers got this most media attention was
the fire festival okay they really this
is it was like a Magic the Gathering
he was like a Magic the Gathering
tournament for racists it was like five
people all of whom took time off from
watching pornography anime pornography
in their grandmother's spare bedroom and
then went over to like a rally and it
was like 10 of them 15 of them and so it
was just absurd Jason Kessler who is the
leader of all of this he got all the
media attention he could possibly want
he was he was confronted the unite the
right to rally and he was asked he was
asked why they were celebrating Heather
hires murder and and it did not go
particularly well for him here is what
it looked like the media we're obviously
all and what's hilarious is that when
you take a longshot view of these of
these protesters well you see is there
20 of them and 100 members of the media
so here's a picture of the rally or
Xindi see what you can see in this
picture is that's it that's it right
there were legitimately more people at
my wife's birthday party over the
weekend and that was just a media family
okay this is it this was the entirety of
the protest hundreds of police officers
show up to protect this thing and the
media covered this thing like it's a big
deal like we are now involved in a
cascading wave of white supremacism
across the United States and this all
right thing they're they're taking over
the country now I want to talk about
what's justified about the
coverage and what's unjustified about
the media coverage and on the flip side
what the media did not cover so let's
talk a little bit about why this was
relevant the reason this is relevant is
because the President of the United
States last year and in the last three
years sort of winked and nodded at the
alt-right he did it during the campaign
I'm not gonna soft-pedal this the
president went on national TV pretended
he didn't know who the KKK was made
coochi faces with the with with Steve
ban and over a Breitbart pretended that
folks in the alt-right were wonderful
nice people and really emboldened them
in 2016
however after that the president then
excised those people from his
administration as he ought to have done
in the first place after Charlotte saw
the president really attempted to push
those people away and that is a good
thing and then the media decided that
they were going to keep that group of
people alive they were going to proclaim
that everybody who is a trump supporter
was in league with these all right
people the President had disassociated
from so the president never should have
associated with those people in the
first place no question and I rip rip
this president and I've ripped this
administration for not having separated
off from those people sooner I was a
chief target of the alt-right during the
2016 campaign and beyond I remain a
chief target of the alt-right today
because I am highly critical of racists
no matter what form they come in the
alt-right is not actually conservative
they're a bunch of idiot racists who
believe that a big government that has
run to the benefit of white people is
the best kind of government it's garbage
it is just sheer stupid garbage and the
fact the president was pandering to
those people during the 2016 campaign
was a real negative for the president it
was a serious problem for him then he
separated off and the question becomes
why are the media covering it now well
the reason we are covering it now is not
because they think this is still a
relevant part of the Trump base the
reason they're covering it now is
because they hope that it is a relevant
part of the Trump base so they can
suggest that the president is still in
league with the all right that's really
what they want here and that's why last
week as I played on the show CNN did a
full report like a full seven eight
minute report on one neo-nazi in the
middle of a rural town in Pennsylvania
where the rest of the town thought the
guy's an idiot but this guy's a crazy
person so they went out and reported on
him because he was a neo-nazi who like
Trump and that made it politically
relevant the problem is the media won't
cover stuff that actually is politically
relevant so the fact is the left has
embraced an Tifa more than the right has
embraced the all right can the alt-right
has basically become so toxic at this
point that 20 people showed up where
hundreds of people showed up last year
now you would imagine that
the alt-right was a swelling burgeoning
crowd then you would have seen thousands
of people in the streets instead what
you saw was 25 guys who were losers and
everybody else running scared from those
people everybody wants to disassociate
now what the left will say is that's
because everybody went underground
everybody went underground and then they
are popping up again in the Trump
administration well I'm not seeing them
pop up in the Trump administration there
are people who are associated with the
alt-right who are popping up in parts of
the right and it is incumbent on people
on the right to actually go out and call
it out when they see it for example Cory
Stewart's staff right in Virginia Cory
Stewart is the Republican candidate for
Senate in Virginia he's gonna get
scorched by Tim Kaine in this latest
election another purple seat that could
have turned red if Republicans hadn't
been idiots in that state Cory Stewart's
campaign has been staffed by a bunch of
alt writers his campaign spokesperson I
believe has all right connections or
said all right things in the past or
allegedly has in any case you know this
sort of stuff has to be excised by the
Conservatives because if we don't excise
this stuff then we will rightly be
lumped in with that stuff in the same
way that the left is being lumped in
with the Democratic Socialist because
they've embraced it the difference is
that most people on the right when asked
about the all right will condemn the
outright most people on the Left will
not condemn the democratic socialists or
even an Tifa a lot of people on the Left
will just ignore an Tifa and this is a
point of real hot-button contention but
over the weekend I was reading a book
called bad news about the situation in
Rwanda and it talks a little bit about
the Rwandan genocide and you know still
a much forgotten genocide despite the
focus that was brought on it in the
1990s 800,000 people murdered within the
span of three months by their neighbors
and it was seriously the government's
are saying to people go out and kill
your neighbor and people would just go
get machetes and they would kill their
neighbor and it occurred to me that one
of the reasons for this may be the chief
reason is that institutional loyalty
combined with polarization is a very
very dangerous thing if you are loyal to
an institution and then people you feel
are attacking that institution and it
becomes more and more polarized or more
and more likely to embrace terrible
things to say terrible things and to do
terrible things and this is true for
both the alt-right and conservatives who
embrace the alt-right and anti feh on
the Left which is embraced by the left
if you believe that your opponent is the
font of all evil and is constantly
attacking you you're more likely to
become reactionary and polarized in to
engage in immoral behavior and that's
why
incumbent on people on the right to say
that we are not going to not only
associate with you alright we are going
to excise them yes they should be
excised that doesn't mean censor it
doesn't mean use government censorship
it does mean that we should not be
appearing on all trite outlets it does
mean that conservatives should be
exercising conspiratorial parts of the
movement you know William F Buckley did
this with the Birch Society and the
right should do the same thing with the
alt-right that she did the same thing
with Alex Jones they should do the same
thing with coops who are inside the tent
those people should be pushed outside of
the tent again that's not censorship
it's not saying Facebook should throw
them out and saying that we should
forcefully speak up against those folks
in those institutions because they are
not us and we are not the same and the
left should be doing the same with hands
- now I think the right there are people
on the right who are attempting to do
this and the question is where to draw
the line but there are people on the
right or really attempting to do this
people on the left or not and here's the
proof so the same weekend that the
alt-right was able to muster a grand
total of twenty doofuses racist pieces
of crap to go rally in Charlottesville
and then head over to Washington DC and
Tifa gathered hundreds of people and
these folks were chanting radical stuff
and the media were just not reporting
this the mainstream media were just not
reporting what an Tifa we're doing over
the weekend there was there was a little
bit of reporting but not much I'm going
to explain what happened but first let's
talk about your coffee you know the
stuff that you are putting in your face
right now the reality is that coffee is
probably weak and it's probably from one
of those awful corporate brands where
they care about bathroom reform policy
and they think you shouldn't have to buy
anything if you sit in there in the
restaurant because they've been
pressured by left wingers well if you
want tough coffee and great coffee with
great people you need black rifle coffee
it's founded by former Special Ops vets
and black rifle delivers the best roasts
to order coffee directly to your door I
know the guys who run black rifle coffee
they are awesome in every way and the
coffee is terrific too it means that you
are guaranteed a fresh premium coffee
with every single order in addition to
great coffee and gear black rifle has a
coffee club that makes things really
easy no lines no running out just
awesome copies shipped right to your
door every month hassle free plus when
you join that coffee Club you receive
discounts offers not available to other
customers not only does black rifle make
a hell of a cup of coffee they also give
a portion of their sales to vets and
first responder causes go check it out
black rifle comm it's black rifle coffee
calm slash been receive 15 percent off
your order that's
rifle coffee calm /ban for 15% off again
black rifle coffee calm /ban a portion
of their sales go to vets and first
responders there is no downside to this
go check it out right now black rifle
coffee calm /ban okay so while the media
we're focused laser-like on Jason
Kessler and his band of narrow duels
auntie foo was showing up in the
hundreds and actually harassing people
so here were protesters and here's what
they were chanting you won't see this
reported anywhere except for right-wing
media protesters who were chanting
legitimately no border no wall no USA at
all where's the left contaminant real
class act you know marching around with
the red flags and wearing masks it's
funny folks on the Left will say well if
you don't need to wear a mask right the
KKK wore masks right and he was wearing
masks too and the fact is that these
people are garbage and they are spouting
garbage and yet the media treat them as
though they're just anti-fascist they
actually take them at face value and you
wonder why folks don't take the media
seriously with all this stuff you wonder
why we think the media are a bunch of
liars when it comes to their coverage of
these issues they'll spend all their
time talking about the dangers of the
alt-right and none of their time talking
about an tyfa it's because they are warm
toward an tifa's cause in the same way
that even today if you say the word
Soviet Union people don't shudder in the
same way that you say Nazi that's
because the media in the United States
decided to treat the Nazis in the Soviet
Union desperately the Nazis should be
treated like the huge sheer human
garbage that they were and are well so
should communists okay hardcore
communists killed more people than the
Nazis and yet we treat communism as
though it is still a valued way of life
something that we ought to think about
we treat people who are communists like
an Tifa as though they are purporting to
speak for something worthwhile there now
again here are these protests over the
weekend again shouting all cops are
races while being protected by cops by
the way
so there they are marching down the
street hundreds of them shouting all
cops are racists while being protected
by the cops all class acts according to
the media these are just anti-fascist
protesters don't you understand these
are like the young men storming the
beaches of Normandy literally over the
last year we've seen that argument in
the pages of the Washington Post that
these are the young people it's just
like Normandy because anti-fascists were
the people storming the beaches of
Normandy and anti-fascists now are like
distorting the beaches of Normandy
except what they're actually doing is
attacking all the police officers
protecting them from the predations of
all right idiots the cops standing
around them they are all racist this is
what we have learned and then the
protesters actually attacked reporters
so imagine if the tea party had attacked
reporters we'd never hear the end of it
right we would they spent in 2010
members of the Democratic Party their
actual hierarchy called the tea party
terrorists they said they were like
domestic terrorists legitimately they
said this over and over and over again I
was a tea partier you might have been a
tea party or two there was not a single
act of violence by the tea party toward
anyone and yet they were treated as
terrorists meanwhile Occupy Wall Street
was protesting in in criminal fashion
they were shutting down freeways there
were rapes going on in Occupy Wall
Street camps and the media didn't cover
it at all well the same thing is
happening now with the alt-right and
antiva the alt-right is disgusting and
awful Antipa is similarly disgusting an
awful and violent here are protesters
from an tyfa attacking NB c-- reporters
over the weekend you see there's an NBC
reporter carrying a camera and then
somebody comes up slaps the camera out
of the MBC reporters hand and starts
shouting at them and then an Tifa cut an
ABC News cable so ABC News was filming
and these antiva members slapped down
the camera and then they proceeded to
cut the sound cable right which is
actual property damage
I got it
struggling with the camera and then they
actually cut the sound cord on this
thing and the idea that progressives
deserve more kudos from the media simply
because of their political point of view
is just disgusting
Benny Johnson over at Daily Caller he
went out in the middle of a progressive
protest and one of these Antipa protests
in front of the White House and he
started asking these folks what they
would do to Trump if Trump were in front
of them and here are some of their
answers we have to do them like hit off
heads a guy wearing a mask all these
people talking about killing the
President of the United States torturing
the President of the United States
don't worry media this isn't worth
covering the stuff that's really worth
covering is those twenty idiots led by
Jason Kessler who couldn't even fill a
train car from Charlottesville to
Washington DC that's where you need to
put all of your attention and now look
and how the Washington Post covered this
okay so the Washington Post did cover
all of the conflict between an Tifa and
the police but here's how they covered
it is legitimately what they tweeted
confusion over an enormous police
presence turned into anger Saturday
night in Charlottesville as hundreds of
protesters marched through the streets
growing angry at police and calling for
an end to white supremacy okay that's
not what happened the police were there
to protect all of the protesters and
then the protesters started chatting
about how all the cops are racist but
listen to how the Washington Post frames
this but they framed it as these evil
fascist police trying to shut down the
protest and then it turned into anger
because the police were the aggressors
that's what that tweet actually says
confusion over an enormous police
presence turned into anger Saturday it
was in confusion they hate cops and they
were ripping on cops and trying to hurt
cops that's all that's all and the
Washington Post continued along these
lines right I mean the Washington Post
had an entire tweet thread talking about
exactly this and they also added
protesters gathered where a year ago
white supremacist had shouted
anti-semitic slogans and carried torches
and chanted slogans against the police
against white supremacy
the University of Virginia look what
changed they were bringing just a year
ago those those outright fascists were
there being terrible people but now you
have these peaceful and Tifa crowds who
all they do is attack cops and try to
attack media members that's all as him
many protesters called the police's
actions on Saturday a provocation
another symbol of the over policing of
America and started chanting at the
officers who are holding shields and
wearing helmets how dare they how dare
they the police and then people wonder
why we don't take the media seriously
they wonder why we think the media are a
joke okay in just a second I'm gonna
show you how much of a joke the media
are but first you're gonna have to go
over to Daley wire.com and subscribe for
$9.99 a month you get to subscribe its
daily we're calm when you do you get the
rest of this show live you get the rest
of Clavin the show live there are some
Michael Moses show live you also get the
benefit with an annual subscription of
this the very greatest in beverage
vessels check this little baby out right
here this leftist cheers hot or a cold
tumbler you will love it you will enjoy
it you will be refreshed by the tears
themselves it is fantastic also go check
us out at YouTube or iTunes please
subscribe please leave this review when
you become a member by the way you also
get first crack in VIP tickets we have
events coming up this week live events
in Dallas and Phoenix those are only the
beginning we will take the United States
by storm and you can have VIP ticket
there Lee's first crack at a VIP ticket
when you get a membership over a daily
wear diamond also helps us bring you the
show it helps us keep all of our folks
employed and all the rest of it so go
check that out please subscribe at
YouTube or iTunes we have a Sunday
special at with Tai Lopez last Sunday we
have a big one coming up next Sunday as
well big guests that I will not name now
but is awesome go check that out
we're the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
all righty so bill de blasio right who
is the who is the mayor of New York he's
been ripping into the media you wonder
about the the media malfeasance the
dishonesty of media brian Stelter at
reliable sources i've been on a show
several times and he's supposed to be
the media watchdog the guy who stands up
for the media right this is somebody who
deeply cares about the freedom of the
press these are the same members of the
press who think NC is okay but the
alt-right is terrible because the all
right is terrible but antiva is not okay
brian Stelter has on de Blasio and de
Blasio starts ripping into the press the
press critical of him of course the New
York Post and Rupert Murdoch and the New
York Daily News he's been terrible for
the local news bill de blasio brian
Stelter says nothing as bill de blasio
goes off on how terrible Rupert Murdoch
is we would be a more unified country
there would be less overt hate there
would be less appeal to racial division
I guarantee it because what Murdoch did
through Fox News and the New York Post
among others is to create a dynamic
where that stuff could come out in the
open we saw in New York City for years
and years where race was infused into
the dialogue in a very negative way and
it was a sort of an apocalyptic vision
was created of the notion of going back
to a time of crime and decay and always
putting that through a lens of people of
color as the villains okay look at these
firefighters like brian Stelter rushing
to the defense of the media right there
did you see how angry brian Stelter was
as a government official basically
suggested that the press was responsible
for everything bad happening America did
you see the field the anger rolling off
of brian Stelter bald head did you feel
it I didn't because it didn't happen
because brian Stelter is holding the
media to a double standard when it's
Rupert Murdoch or Fox News and it's okay
for politicians to bash them but when
it's CNN CNN must never ever be bashed
it is very bad when the President of the
United States says CNN sucks and CNN is
fake news but it is fine when Bill
DeBlasio who's an awful awful commie
mayor of New York when he comes forward
and he says that the New York Post is
terrible for America Rupert Murdoch is
terrible for America then of course not
a problem at all
and then you wonder why Trump's anti
media message resonates it resonates
because for legitimately my entire life
the media have been this bad the same
media that cover France Haifa the same
media that suggest that we ought not be
worried
in the slightest about left-wing
violence we should only be worried about
right-wing violence even though
left-wing violence happens against
police officers at these rallies from
Antigua on a routine basis
those same media members are fine with
attacks from politicians on right-wing
media sources or even mildly moderate
media sources yeah maybe we shouldn't
trust the media maybe shouldn't trust me
and this goes to a real question the
infiltration of both parties by the
extremes of the parties is is is it
growing or is it shrinking is it growing
or is it shrinking it's hard to tell at
this point so I mentioned a little bit
earlier Corey Stewart and the fact that
Corey Stewart is the Senate candidate in
Virginia and that Corey Stewart his
campaign has been deeply ensconced with
the alt-right and that's really gross
and then I've talked about the fact that
NCI has infiltrated the left his Corey
Stewart the future of the GOP and is Al
Sharpton the future of the left it sort
of seems like that could be the that
could be the future of both parties
unless reasonable stands a reasonable
people stand up and say no yeah I'm
gonna explain that in just second but
here was Corey Stewart versus Al
Sharpton is this the future of American
politics right here on MSNBC there are
Americans of every single race of every
single religion of every single
ethnicity that are struggling with the
same things and as long as we continue
to divide Americans by race and you've
made a career out of dividing people by
race you've been a race hustler your
entire career you've made a lot of money
at it you haven't even bothered to pay
your taxes by race okay
well Corey Stewart is saying about Al
Sharpton is a hundred percent correct
but our rap thing could say the same
thing about Corey Stewart who's from
Minnesota has proclaimed that he is for
the southern legacy then these
Confederate memorials have to be
maintained now there's a case for
maintaining Confederate memorials as a
lesson from the past I think it's
Condoleezza Rice's case which is that we
shouldn't obliterate history just
because history is uncomfortable for us
when we see statues of people who are
controversial or bad we should look at
them and we should remember we should
teach our kids based on this fact that
those statues were erected in the first
place Corey Stewart his campaign has
been a real problem
Rick shafting who runs communications
for Stewart has said really terrible
stuff in the past about black folks and
black neighborhoods and all the rest he
still works for Corey Stewart Corey
Stewart has suggested that
the South legacy is fighting the civil
war which is just awful the civil war
was was a very very bad war fought on
behalf of slavery okay but the fact that
the right some people on the right have
embraced Cory Stuart because they hate
the left so much and a lot of people
have left have embraced how Sharpton
because then they hate the right so much
that is a recipe for disaster in the
country the left should be called on to
disavow people like Al Sharpton who's
continuously been a major player in the
Democratic Party for thirty years after
claiming race hoaxes after race hoax and
people on the right should be disavowing
Cory Stewart and that whole wing of the
Republican Party because this cannot be
the future of the two-party system if it
is then what we are going to see is
going to be a nation that gets uglier
and uglier and I understand people want
to vote from one side to stop the other
side but if we don't have some
intellectual honesty from both sides
then this is the future the future is
going to be an increased polarization
due to loyalty to institutions and then
those institutions become even more
polarized even more reactionary an even
more dangerous this stuff has got to
stop we have to start drawing lines at
the left must draw lines against an Tifa
it must draw lines against
intersectional politics and identity
politics and the right must draw lines
against identity politics on its own
side there's an end conspiracy
theorizing by the way this crap has to
stop okay now speaking of crap that has
to stop and just did it turns out that
today the FBI fired Peter struck that
only took 97 years okay Peter struck
you'll recall is the FBI
counterintelligence agents who came
under withering criticism because he had
been texting with his lover Lisa Paige
about how terrible President Trump was
and then he texted that he was going to
stop President Trump from becoming
president and it only took 1000 years
for him to be fired
according to Struck's lawyer a time
Golemon an internal disciplinary review
had been had recommended Struck's
demotion and a 60-day suspension but
goldman said monday the deputy of the
director director of the FBI overruled
that determination and decided to fire
him the decision to fire special agent
struck is not only an apartment
departure from typical bureau practice
but also contradicts director ray's
testimony to Congress and his assurances
that the FBI intended to follow its
regular process in this and all other
personnel matters said strux lawyer the
reality is that struck should have been
fired long ago obviously the in the
inspector general review Michael
Horowitz his review over at the
Department of Justice found that Peter
struck could not have been trusted to
actually handle the Hillary Clinton
investigation or the
investigation and that his decisions may
have been biased by his bias against
President Trump and they had real
ramifications for both investigations
struck should have been fired long ago
the fact that he continued to maintain
his innocence throughout all of this was
always seriously questionable now we are
still awaiting the Inspector General
report on the Russia investigation and
how much personal bias impacted the the
procedure in the investigation but there
are serious questions to be asked
another one of those serious questions
comes courtesy of John Solomon over at
the hill who has a long piece today
talking about the relationship between
fusion GPS and a guy named Bruce or
who's working for the FBI at the time
here's what John Solomon writes he says
in a memory stick quietly exchanged in a
coffee shop an admission of a hail-mary
leak an unmistakable effort to push the
Russia investigation closer to Donald
Trump's inner circle with uncorroborated
tales these are just some of the
highlights from the day that fusion GPS
founder Glenn Simpson paid for by
Hillary Clinton's campaign met secretly
with the top Justice Department official
right after Trump won the 2016 election
all of it was captured in the officials
handwritten notes a contemporaneous
record that intelligence professionals
tell me exposes the flaws plaguing the
early Russia collusion case for example
Glenn Simpson who you'll recall was
working for fusion GPS that was the firm
that was hired to do Oppo on Trump by
Hillary Clinton told that associate
Deputy Attorney General Bruce or during
a December 10 2016 meeting in a
Washington coffee shop that he believed
Trump's longtime lawyer Michael Kohn was
a go-between from Russia to the Trump
campaign now Bruce ORS wife actually
worked for the for the fusion GPS firm
Simpson allegedly acknowledged most of
the information from fusion GPS and
British intelligence operative
Christopher Steele did not come from
sources inside Moscow they said there's
a Russian source in the United States
who'd been providing them the
information that makes it very suspect
as to whether that information was
reliable in any way still fusion GPS was
funneling all of this information over
to Bruce or over at the FBI
congressional investigators according to
John Solomon are now scouring all of
Bruce ORS notes for evidence that
Simpson and Steele had influence over
the Russia probe even after Steele was
dismissed as an FBI informant in
November 2016 investigators want to know
if any players in the Russia probe gave
Congress false
one notation that stands out is Simpsons
account that he asked Steele to talk
with Mother Jones reporter David corn
about the muck ranking on Trump and
Russia in the final days of the election
at the time Steele was still working as
an FBI source so apparently the idea
here is that fusions GPS leaked all this
information to david korn and that story
was intended to blow trump up before the
election now that's not illegal right it
was an apple research hit but if they
were leaking secret inside information
from the FBI then that is illegal
obviously Simpsons lawyer is not
returning call seeking comment the
question is what was Bruce were doing
when was he doing it and this is still
the open question in all of this what
exactly was the impact of the bias
against President Trump inside the FBI
as they pursued their their
investigation in the Russia
investigation we still don't know the
Russian investigation allegedly even
according Devon Nunez was the house
intelligent even that was initiated
based on George papadopolis but it is
unclear how much that investigation was
infiltrated by people who did not like
Trump and were attempting to use that
investigation to quote-unquote get Trump
either before or after the election
there are serious questions that still
have to be asked about all of that and
President Trump isn't wrong to be deeply
frustrated with all of that he just
tweeted out this morning agent Peters
truck was just fired from the FBI
finally the list of bad players in the
FBI and DOJ gets longer and longer based
on the fact that struck was in charge of
the witch-hunt will it be dropped it is
a total hoax no collusion no obstruction
I just fight back just fired agent
struck formerly of the FBI it was in
charge of the crooked Hillary Clinton
sham investigation it was a total fraud
on the American public and should be
properly redone so now he's calling on
his DOJ to reprosecution Clinton we'll
see how that plays out you know I'm not
sure that that's a wise move that said
the president ought to be very
frustrated with his DOJ and FBI he has
every right to do so okay time for some
things I like and then some things that
I hate so things I like today so I
referenced this book I was reading on
wanza over the weekend recommended to me
by my friend Jane Koston it's called I
asked her for some books that you'd
recommend on politics in Africa cuz I
really don't know that much about it the
book is called bad news last journalist
in a dictatorship by Angela Sundaram
now it's a very good book the the
qualification I have is that it's
endorsed by Noam Chomsky which always
makes me think twice about the book
I think what the book does really well
is it does show you how dictatorship to
run it does show you the threat to
journalists particularly in
dictatorships and the danger of
dictatorships in turning a population
into a subject population willing to do
the will of the dictator that said I
don't know enough marijuana and politics
to be honest with you to tell you
whether there are any viable
alternatives to the Kagame regime in
Rwanda which has been highly successful
at boosting the economy while at the
same time suppressing public dissent in
the aftermath of the Rwandan genocide
there are a lot of folks who think maybe
a maybe dictatorship is almost necessary
because democracy would break down
immediately into civil war again I don't
know enough about Rwanda to give you a
straight answer on that all I can tell
you that the book does provide a window
into how people think that the most
interesting part of this book because
there's a section where a Kagame
basically orders a bunch of people
inside Rwanda to take down the thatched
roof huts that they have these they
don't have modern roofing in in Rwanda
because a very poor country still and
all these people basically dismantle the
roofs on their own homes without any
sort of replacement for them and only
asked about it by sundaram the author of
this book they say listen we were told
to do so and we have to modernize the
country so of course we would take down
our own roofs once you have people who
are willing to do stuff that does not
benefit them and actually is highly
damaging simply because someone told
them to do it you have a population that
is in serious danger of reverting to to
violence at the drop of a hat and that's
a serious problem it's why I said
earlier on the show institutional
loyalty combined with radical
polarization is a serious danger of
violence that's what creates a serious
danger of violence you know don't be a
follower be an individual when you start
thinking of yourself as a member of a
collective as opposed to a member of an
individual you start to say okay two
things you never would have said okay
two before okay other things that I like
so this video which is from November
2017 is really pretty amazing this is a
video of a Brazilian surfer setting the
world record for surfing the largest
wave his name is Rodrigo coxa look at
this video this is this wave is 80 feet
tall look at this there's no there's no
sound on it but you can it's
unbelievable I mean it looks like he's
surfing a tsunami basically it's just
ridiculous and I have to say you know
the the fact that this guy is willing to
undertake that I mean good for him but
holy moley sometimes you just have to
admire the skill look at that that's
real speed right there how you survived
that is beyond me but professionals and
professionals
I mean Bodie from Point Break signals
his approval so amazing stuff there okay
time for a quick thing that I hate then
we'll do a federalist paper okay so
today's a thing that I hate so Nancy
Pelosi I think really spills the beans
here she wants to be Speaker of the
House again and she basically says to
Democratic candidates go ahead and lie
to the American public lie to them that
you don't like me lie to them you won't
make me speaker do whatever you have to
do to win and then you want to write
people don't trust politicians you
wonder why Trump is president one of the
reasons Trump is president is because
there is a baseline level of dishonesty
that is baked into our politics the
reality is that if the Democrats regain
the house they will make Nancy Pelosi
Speaker again that is a talking point
for Republicans but Democrats are dis
abusing their voters of the idea that
they're gonna back Pelosi even though
they're lying and she's fine if you have
to lie why lie to get in power okay well
if that's our politics then no wonder
that President Trump who is routinely
dishonest about things no wonder that
the American public just discount the
dishonesty they say he's honest about
the big things who cares if he's
dishonest about the small things Nancy
Pelosi is certainly no better I do
believe that none of us is indispensable
but I think I'm the best person for the
job and I won't let the Republican ads
which are just flooding these districts
and I say the candidates do whatever you
have to do just win baby
I know one in five children America
lives in poverty we must win this okay
so basically lie as much as you can to
get power I wonder why we don't trust
our politicians and we're willing to
elect anybody who even has the slightest
semblance of a non-politician
I can't imagine okay time for a quick
Federalist Papers so we're all the way
up to Federalist 41 making steady
progress through the Federalist Papers
Federalist 41 written by James Madison
and he talks about the power is
necessary for the government to function
properly so this particular Federalist
paper asks two questions the first
question is whether any of the powers
transfer to the general government are
unnecessary or improper meaning is the
government grabbing more power than it
needs and second whether it could be
dangerous to give this kind of power to
the federal government he says it's
pretty clear that all the power is
delegated to the federal government
under the Constitution are necessary and
then the answer is yes of course the
and could misuse the powers he says in
every political institution a power to
advance the public happiness involves a
discretion miss made which may be miss
applied and abused right of course
anytime you give the government the
power to care a problem it could also
make the problem twice as bad
by usurping to itself additional power
he says this is the reason why the
Constitution has checks and balances and
it is why the Constitution is a document
of enumerated powers now this is deeply
important there are a lot of folks on
the Left who think that the Constitution
is important because of the Bill of
Rights the Bill of Rights is the least
important part of the Constitution the
most important part of the Constitution
is the structural Constitution the part
of the Constitution that says how the
government works the government is only
supposed to have a certain number of
enumerated powers right powers that are
spelled out that the government has all
other powers do not belong to the
government
according to Madison the government has
six types of powers security against
foreign danger regulation of intercourse
with foreign nations that would be trade
maintenance of harmony and proper
intercourse among the states that would
be preventing the states from terrifying
each other basically certain
miscellaneous objects of general utility
which is like post offices and stuff
restraint of the states from certain
injurious acts he can prevent the state
from usurping power from the feds and
provisions for giving to efficacy to all
these powers so that's what the
Necessary and Proper Clause is the
Constitution allows the government to do
what it needs to do in order to
effectuate those clauses but he also
points out a principle a principle of
interpretation so he says what we can't
do is look at the Constitution see a
power and then expand the actual scope
of the government to everything it gives
an example he says a power to destroy
the freedom of the press the trial by
jury or even to regulate the course of
dissents or the forms of conveyances
must be very singularly expressed by the
terms to raise money for the general
welfare and he explicitly points out an
argument people on the Left use they say
well look the Constitution says the
government has the power to provide for
the general welfare that means income
tax I mean socialized health care no
says Madison what color can this
objection have when a specification of
the objects alluded to by these general
terms immediately follows and is not
even separated by a longer pause than a
semicolon in other words when it says to
raise money for the general welfare and
then it lists all of the things you can
do that you can do with that clause that
is a comprehensive list it doesn't mean
that the general rule overrides the
specifics it means the specifics govern
the
and this is true in its basic principle
of constitutional interpretation the
specific governs the general the general
does not govern the specific if I say to
you I want you to go to the supermarket
and here's a list of objects I want you
to pick up at the supermarket I don't
mean go to the supermarket and buy
anything you want the specifics governed
the general the same thing is true in
contractual negotiation and a contracted
contractual interpretation and it's true
when it comes to the Constitution if the
Constitution says the government has the
power to provide for the general welfare
and then lists for pages all the stuff
the government can do it's all the stuff
the government can do the matters it is
not that motivating clause to provide
for the general welfare as Madison says
for what purpose could the enumeration
of particular powers be inserted if
these and all others were meant to be
included in the preceding general power
and that of course is exactly right and
this is why originalism is correct when
it comes to constitutional
interpretation just as you would read a
contract literally by looking at the
specific terms you have to look at the
Constitution and read it literally by
looking at the specific terms okay we
will be back here tomorrow with all the
latest i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wah
of era the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire for word publishing production
copyright Ford publishing 2018